have you ever seen an atom seeing as
everything's made of them you have but
have you ever seen one on its own over
time microscopes have become more and
more powerful allowing us to see deeper
into the world of the ultra small
traditional light microscopes can be
used to see things like these onion
cells and the structures within them as
they divide pulling apart their
chromosomes but scientists have come up
with a whole host of clever methods to
observe far smaller things using beams
of electrons instead of light we can
generate detailed images of chromosomes
themselves recently groups of scientists
around the world are becoming able to
see materials at the most fundamental
scale the atomic
one group from the University of
California in Los Angeles have been
getting up close and personal with
nanoparticles of platinum just a few
nanometers across each of the tiny dots
you can see here are actually individual
platinum atoms but researchers didn't
stop at a two-dimensional picture by
imaging over a hundred slices of the
nanoparticle at different angles then
removing the noise with a special filter
they were able to map the location of
almost every atom the information was
used to create a three-dimensional
reconstruction of the whole particle in
unprecedented detail
it may look blurry but this particle is
estimated to contain over 27,000 atoms
and so like flies in a swarm they appear
to merge together every so often though
we see the Platinum's atomic structure
align granting us a moment of clarity
this technique is being used to analyze
tiny irregularities in the structure of
the particle called dislocations
dislocations are subtle like the
misalignment of the green and red layers
of atoms in this particle but
nonetheless they can significantly
change the properties of materials with
effects ranging from a change in the
efficiency of LEDs to the strength of
metal alloys three-dimensional
atomic-scale imaging like this is
bettering our understanding of the
structure of materials on this truly
fundamental scale
you